columnas de humo salen de este edificio
después de ser alcanzado por un misil
como supuesto objetivo de rusia según
las autoridades ucranianas
un misil enemigo alcanzó un edificio
residencial en el centro de jarquín como
el edificio es residencial no podemos
descartar la posibilidad de que haya
otras personas atrapadas bajo los
escombros
esta mujer vive dentro del edificio
donde casi queda atrapada
la explosión y la sacudida del edificio
fueron fuertes queríamos salir pero
nuestra puerta se atascó sólo quedaba un
hueco pequeño queríamos abrirla pero la
puerta del vecino estaba arrancada y
bloqueado a nuestra puerta ya no pudimos
salir más mientras tanto se han
reanudado los bombardeos cerca de la
central nuclear de sabor' y allá un día
después de que el organismo
internacional de la energía atómica
pidiera a ambas partes que delimitarán
una zona segura para evitar una
catástrofe en respuesta las autoridades
ucranianas dicen estar considerando
cerrar la planta por completo el club
ians que en el este del donbass también
continúan los combates y los bombardeos
los misiles impactan en las casas y los
residentes están cada vez más cansados
hubo una guerra en 2014 y ahora hay una
guerra de nuevo
ucraniano retrocede sus líderes dicen
que la contraofensiva que iniciaron en
agosto sigue en marcha el objetivo es
retomar las zonas controladas por rusia
incluyendo las zonas como crimea que se
anexionaron hace 8 años